Chantell what do you think about mouth
but you like it today we're waiting
full-body velour head-to-toe I was
looking on a so saw a bunch of a lower
stuff and I was like what is this is
this 2007 this has been not a stop for a
long time why are we bringing this back
it's kind of embarrassing to think about
that the last time I wore velour I was
like 13 in my head I was the most
stylish kid in school I used to be hot
back in the day like 90s hip-hop rocker
where Sean John fat farm FUBU everybody
was rocking them from P Diddy to Jay Z I
know velour from Jessica Simpson Dave
there's something days I don't know what
you'd come back you might feel like a
soft blanket if it's dope and I loved
open it I'll still rock it you came went
through in order is all
color-coordinated things industry came
for him he's not gonna do anything
half-assed my outfit I based it on green
and pink do people wear this for pajamas
like I don't know what time of day
people actually wear this this is what I
will write gold trim
look at that I like gold and I love
Burgundy not filling the pants at all
I actually love the pink detailing to
match this little hat here I remember
when bucket hats were everything you're
not on a boat and you're not fishing you
don't need this hat this reminds me of
middle school with like the square pizza
so we're gonna wear this morning
afternoon and night and cares what
people will say I'm hiking in this suit
is it fun it's not that fun I'm not
gonna lie the students warm I'm sweating
under my hat but I mean I look cute
right yeah you look so comfortable so
jealous I may not be able to walk this
out but LL Cool J
oh boy yeah you look like you're about
to do that we're doing it well doing it
very wrong I'll take over again look
it's always fun to touch oh that's so
weird it feels like a bunch of
caterpillars going across my hands I
want to see your softer baby son hey let
it play a place and look at you I wanted
to ask a fashion question which hat do
you think is better
I like the all pink cuz that's a look I
don't love before did you have a velour
tracksuit no but I want one guys need to
like step out more and do weird fashion
things
I thought you look really good it shows
off your body your body looks a grave in
this it was like a boys 2 men kind of
like throwback do you think the trend
should come back yes
I'm such a fan of the lore me look at my
sweater this is like a Navy's thing I
think this is like peak gotta go I feel
like you've hit the right tone right
here forever I'm now wearing your
insides on the outside you look like the
bomb calm your back yo so you're saying
I'm pulling this off yes
juicy across the booth this shirt has
gotten a lot of compliments even from
people who don't know I'm doing a video
will be like cool shirts I feel a lot
more fashion-forward even though it's
from the past here walking the streets
of LA and everybody's looking like what
year is this guy yeah that's the number
one question people keep asking look at
that jumpsuit is it like 2007 this town
is coming back supposed to be
you like a turtle from the marrow this
there's no judgment here oh we all here
in LA can I go back to the block of New
York in my eyes I don't know about going
back to the block right there by they
you can wear whatever you want no
judgment this is true paradise you rock
this [ __ ] nice on me damn about to go to
the movie I feel like a character right
now I feel like a dad in this outfit
actually with this hat who posted the
group photos and individual photos on
Instagram and got overwhelmingly
positive responses people seem to really
be into it I think cuz it really stands
out it's not something that people
normally wear at least in our generation
people were commenting looking like a
snack dad and that we look like pokemon
trainers which I agree we do the end of
the day it would be a porter the other
people like this is ho ho and I tried my
best
sometimes it gets tiring that didn't
like his outfit okay I don't insure what
I'd do it again now when I did this
again I've turned 31 this month I've
been Ida's outfit really aged debates
there were a lot of strong opinions
about the lore a lot of people wanted to
pet me I would definitely wear it again
you just feel very comfortable but fancy
because actually she's already started
wearing it in my wardrobe okay I wish
that I was back home in Missouri it
actually gets cold there I got so many
compliments today I'm gonna focus on
those compliments that way my dreams
people will see this outfit they'll be
like damn Ryan you're the most
fashionable dream person ever the most
fashionable person in these dreams right
do you live in the Lord
No there you have a Judy set on like
Marvin lure the Lord the Lord if you
gonna wear it I always say Butler it
doesn't matter because it honestly needs
just stayed back to where was the Lord
the Lord